okay we're in Vegas which it's morning
in Vegas which means we partied too hard
last night I don't know who's the most
hungover I'd say probably me I'm Dylan I
went to bed at 10 p.m. 10 p.m.
you would've been at 10 p.m. in Vegas
right so before we came to Vegas I sent
out a tweet asking where we should get
hangover in one place sort of stood out
that people recommended
it's called Comex so we're on our way
now to Comex Comex we're gonna see just
how good Korean and Mexican food
ara curing our hangover I'm gonna give
you a nice large lap I feel like one
thing that's nice when you're hungover
is to just lean against the brick wall
is that real brick I can't tell it's not
real not real sorry you're having such a
rough morning what's the history of
Comex well we actually own a Mexican
market for over 20 years we would bring
home Google
means the creepy and all of that and my
husband would just actually make the
pico de gallo he had tortillas it's kind
of wrap it up and eat it with Mexican
rice whatever we had at the market
that's awesome we want to eat everything
it's got fries and it's got chippies
whoa baby
go it tastes like Korean barbecue it's
like french fries it's fun to be messy
when you're hungover have like a nice
messy meal opinions Isis spicy it awakes
yourself ups baby
yeah man they know how to fit this thing
why I'm happy over this volume right now
the spice of it opens up my hungover
closed sinuses I want to say it's like
if Taco Bell's are very very very good
cuz you know how taco bells always like
will would if it's a pizza
what's better than nacho surprise potato
tot that's what's better and I can't
believe that they understand that and
that they serve this as a meal the tater
tots are golden they're perfect
not very hey no you're a little baby
little little baby you're not gonna be
able to eat that bite we're going no
that's not how anyone wants anyone else
to eat it felt like them my cheeks just
started sagging to the floor cuz they're
filled with such delicious meat there's
nothing I like more than stuffing my
face with NATO guys yeah look at your
face while you speak to me anymore
go get chimichanga so you've got it
looks like a Mexican chimichanga but
instead it
be in there your slaw smells so good
feel like this isn't gonna be too bad on
my stomach it is somehow light I don't
feel like it all right I feel like I
feel light as a feather this is what
hanging over food is about it should
look beautiful when it arrives and
immediately a disaster on your plate but
like a disaster that you want to lick up
every drop of hangover food shouldn't
become a beautiful disaster like your
night prior oh this is kind of like one
just big jumbo at one flavor this is
more uniform whereas the other one was
like hey have a little bit of this
where's this crunch coming from I'm
waking up certainly I feel like a lot
better I'm starting to feel better after
a drunken night out want something spicy
and so this is a kimchi chicken fried
rice can I pop the yolk you can pop the
yolk bro yeah you did this so why did
you do it like that I'm sorry
I actually normally don't eat kimchi
because I know that kids you spicy and
normally when I'm about to eat it one of
my friends says mmm milky tone eat this
cool it's like a civic spicy sometimes
spice is a great way to wake yourself up
that's true and this kimchi is just
clearing up my sinuses opening up my
eyes and get me ready for the day at
cream barbecue places a lot of times
don't finish grilling everything and
then when they're done they'll take all
that grease oh man make kimchi fried
rice oh oh it's so good
this is just belly cement basically
they're really tasty belly cement I just
I just love rice you know fried rice
white rice steamed rice sticky rice
we're gonna get a little sweat oh I'm
sorry listen I'm gonna start to glisten
so how does my hangover now as compared
to earlier I do feel better than earlier
more energetic
ready to prove it my hangover now is
definitely improved and kind of look
like hell a couple hours I felt like
hell but now I feel like a person Thank
You Comex coming out of a hangover is
one of the great joys in life and the
totally sober person I really enjoyed
that meal but I feel like I went in
reverse of where you guys are because I
started off this morning very the way
and now I'm at that like food baby food
coma moment